Captain Rambeau
What the hell are you doing?
Entering the jump point perimeter.
I'm going to get you some readings
Fury
Hello?
Hello.
Rambeau, is.
Is it Avengers Test
Where’s Captain Rambeau
What the hell
Hi. We're looking for Kamala Khan.
Okay, so our powers are entangled.
I can manipulate light energy. And you.
I can totally show you
again. Hi.
Where's our daughter?
Wherever you were
Shields Up
We're a team.
No, no, no, no, we're not.
We're not a team.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Marvel just dropped the Marvel's trailer.
Captain Marvel two.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The big thing in this movie is
they're actually going to start paying off
some of the bigger Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty references
like the Incursions, Time runs out.
They don't really get to that
during the trailer footage,
but that's like one of the big things
that they're getting into.
They use the Beastie Boys
song Intergalactic
because it is a very intergalactic, space
based movie.
During the movie, we're supposed to see
an actual incursion start to happen.
It has something to do
with the power of Ms.
Marvel's
Bangles, the two different bangles
which we see Dar-Benn
wielding the other bangle for a long time.
People wondering if Kamala Khan's
other bangles that they've been looking
for for all these years that her mother
and her people have been looking for
was actually Shang Chi's
ten rings of power.
This confirms that that's not the case.
The other bangle just looks like her
one bangle, like they both look
the exact same.
This just confirms that the Bangles
are a version of the three Nega bands.
There might be some more connections
to Kang.
The Conqueror
because the rings on his device during Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania look similar.
But in order
for that connection to be made,
they would have to say the kang
made the kree Nega bands.
We might also get some mutants in X-Men
Easter Eggs too,
because they just canonized Ms..
Marvel as a mutant in the MCU, they use
the X-Men, the animated series theme song.
When they were talking about that
at the end of Ms..
Marvel entering Wandavision
Darcy referenced Monica Rambeau's
DNA being mutated
as if she was becoming a mutant.
They started the trailer on Nick
Fury of Space Station.
You notice the texture says Saber Space
Station like sword, as in saber.
I think what they're saying here
is that Tyler Hayward during Wandavision
was only a part of sword doing
something really shady.
Nick Fury had been in charge of Sword
the whole time,
like a lot of us had assumed.
But they get into it
way more during the movie.
They just tease at the end of Spider-Man,
far from home.
It will probably get a little teaser for
it during Marvel's Secret Invasion series.
That's the next big series.
It's a big Nick Fury series.
Obviously, they're going to use that
to promote the Marvel's movie.
There'll be some connection
to what's happening during the Marvel's.
Also, the whole idea that the Kree
and the Skrulls
are so endemic
to Captain Marvel story in the MCU.
Nick Fury story.
Of course
there be some connection
with the Marvel's movie,
only some of the story
is supposed to take place on Earth.
Like you see a couple of scenes with them
at Kamala Khan's house
trying to figure out what's going
on, some of
the scenes of them on the space station
trying to get ready for a big Kree attack.
But it seems like most of the footage
actually takes place in
Kree Scrolls Space,
like on the other side of the galaxy.
That's basically where Captain Marvel
has been this whole time.
During the movie.
They'll explain why Carol Danvers
hasn't come back more often
just because there's so many references
and Easter eggs, like Ms..
Marvel is supposed to be
a big fangirl of her character,
even though she was barely around
doing Avengers Endgame.
It hasn't been around on Earth
publicly in a long time.
Monica Rambeau had the whole subplot
during Wandavision
where she was really pissed off
at Captain Marvel,
but they never explained why.
The whole idea is that she thinks that
she didn't come back to support her
mother when her mother was dying of cancer
during the whole blip.
The five year time jump.
I believe the movie's supposed to explain
that Captain Marvel really did
come back and visit.
It was just on the DL in Monica Rambeau.
We'll start to understand
what was really going on,
because a big part of the trailer,
like the message
during the trailer, when they say teaming
up, changes everything and everyone.
The whole idea is that
there are swapping spots because of Ms..
Marvel's Bangle.
They teased that during the Ms..
Marvel Post-Credits scene where Captain
Marvel literally swaps places with Ms..
Marvel like their body swap places.
They have a couple of funny jokes
about that through the trailer
where they don't know what's going
on. They'll just keep swapping places,
especially in the middle
of their big fights. During the movie.
They'll be forced to team up
against their will.
Like Monica Rambeau, Captain Marvel
seem in the trailer like that.
One had nothing to do with it. Like,
No, no, no. We're not a team.
Forget about this.
But Ms..
Marvel is acting kind of like Spider-Man
with Iron Man the whole time.
That's
meant to be the vibe of her character.
This is they're treating her a little bit
like Spider-Man was
when he was nerding out on The Avengers
with Iron Man's character in Iron Man.
Couldn't
stand it like not pop culture references.
No more Star Wars references, please.
Ms.. Marvel is meant to be an Avengers
fangirl just like that.
Like she's so excited when Nick Fury
shows up with Monica Rambeau.
Oh my God,
Is this an audition for the Avengers?
Do I get to be on The Avengers
now throughout the movie?
By the time
they get to the final fight with Dar-Benn
here, who's using the other bangle,
they learn to use the power
to their benefit.
We see them all swapping places, all
three of them fighting her three on one.
But they start the trailer at the peak
with Nick Fury wondering
where Monica Rambeau is.
She's in a space station
looking at one of the jump points nearby.
Those are the jump points
that everybody uses in the Marvel Universe
that don't have the Bifrost ability,
like Thor
with Stormbreaker
to just open up wormholes at will.
They had a big joke about that
during Guardians of Galaxy two, where they
plotted a route through too many wormholes
and it just messed them up big time.
In As she's touching the jump gate this
near Earth, she swaps places with Ms..
Marvel and they have the joke about her
seeing Nick
Fury wondering
if this Avengers tests like,
Are you trying to test me to see
if I get to join The Avengers?
Now, another big Avengers reference too,
because during the Secret Invasion trailer
they also reference that like
where are The Avengers?
In? The whole idea is that Nick
Fury hasn't got around
to assembling a new Avengers team yet.
They'll probably reference
that during the movie too.
You notice Monica Rambeau
getting ready to detach the jump point.
The physical jump point here
is meant to be a callback to Wandavision
where she was touching the hex.
You see almost a similar
looking type of energy
given off when she starts to touch it,
but then switches with Ms..
Marvel because of the bangle and you get
that purple energy that comes off of Ms..
Marvel's bangle every time she uses it.
Like the energy of the power
looks like Ms.. Marvel's powers.
You remember at the end of Wandavision,
one of the Post-Credits
scenes was for Monica Rambeau,
where the scroll came to take her to
Nick Fury to become a more important
in his inner circle within Sword.
The point is
that she's been working for Sword
on the space station ever since then.
And you notice, too,
when Nick Fury is watching
Kamala Khan show up like,
what the hell is going on here?
Getting ready to drop some classic Nick,
very F-bombs on his desk.
You actually see Captain
Marvel's souped up space pager.
You also notice
that he's still wearing his eyepatch.
He wasn't wearing it
during the Secret Invasion series.
I think the reason they're doing that
daring secret invasion
is that one of the skrulls,
one of the evil skrulls,
the different sect will actually walk
around with his eyepatch
pretending to be Nick Fury
so that when you see him on screen,
you know which one is the real Nick Fury?
He'll be the one without the eyepatch.
You also notice
that Kamala Khan knows exactly
who Nick Fury is when she sees him,
even though he has no idea who she is.
When they switch places,
he knows that Monica Rambeau winds up
switching with Carol Danvers
and winds up on this alien planet
in a different part of space,
dropping out of this wormhole
like they all rotate
down the line to different places.
But that's where we get to Chris Space
because that's where Carol Danvers was,
which is how they pull the story
back to that part of the galaxy.
In Monica, Rambeau sees the captain.
Marvel was in the middle of a fight
with his Kree army.
Here you see a couple of the pink skin,
Kree with the naturally colored Kree two.
And you see her
use her power to repel them.
Like she tells Ms..
Marvel and her parent during the trailer,
she manipulates light energy.
It seems that
they actually tuned her down.
I did a much longer video
about how her powers work in the comics.
One of the reasons
why the title of the movie is called
The Marvel is instead of just calling it
Captain Marvel two
is because all three of the characters
have the Captain Marvel name
or have had it at one point.
It's a bit of a play.
On the idea
that Monica Rambeau in the comics
was the original female Captain Marvel.
She actually had the Captain Marvel
name way before,
like many, many years
before the Carol Danvers
character ever started using the Captain
Marvel name. And Ms..
Marvel literally has that
name in her title like she is Ms..
Marvel to Captain Marvel.
Ms.. Marvel was also a name,
The Carol Danvers
went by originally in the comics, too,
but they kind of skipped that in the MCU.
A lot of people now
wondering if the Blue Marvel is going
to have a cameo scene during this,
because we all thought
that he was going to show up
during the Wandavision series
with all the sword stuff.
If they were going
to introduce him in the MCU
any time soon, any different property
or any different series or movie,
I do believe it would be through
the Captain Marvel storyline.
This scene of Captain Marvel
switching with Ms..
Marvel is literally just the Ms..
Marvel Post-Credits scene.
It's like the exact same footage.
They actually said that the crew
that was filming the Marvel's
movie film that Post-Credits
scene for the series last year,
she came out of the closet
and she starts looking around Ms..
Marvel's room like,
What the hell is going on here?
She thinks she's stepped
into some sort of stalkers room.
She starts seeing all the fanart of her
with Ms..
Marvel, like Kamala Khan and Captain
Marvel working together.
A lot of the art in the background
is literally
just taken from comic book art,
like comic book covers.
You notice on her desk
she has a model of Iron Man's helmet.
There's an Iron Man figure on the desk
on the other side here, too.
That's because just in general,
she is an Avengers
fan girl, but also in real life,
the actress who plays Ms..
Marvel is an Iron Man fan girl.
Her favorite film of all time
is the First Iron Man.
So naturally, because it's a great film,
one of the funny things about the Ms..
Marvel series
is they say that there were too many
Iron Man references during because she was
such a fangirl when she was filming Ms..
Marvel.
She kept trying to make Iron Man
references and Kevin Feige,
he's like, No, please stop
referencing Iron Man so much.
This is more about Captain Marvel.
You're supposed to be a Captain Marvel
fan girl.
You notice the sloth references.
That's a reference to her YouTube
channel, Sloth
Baby Productions,
where she makes the Avengers
fan films like she's got the page
open to one of her Avengers fan pages.
This lot, Baby pages.
This is a piece of comic book art,
but done to look like Brie Larson.
Some of these posters of Captain
Marvel are actually literally real
life posters taken from the first movie.
They actually did that during Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania,
where the little Kids
backpack was just one of the posters
from the very first movie
they gave them a brand new Marvel Studios
intro logo
like they do with every single movie
updating it,
which is the most recent stuff
that has come out.
Like you see
both She-Hulk and Moon Knight in this.
They cut the logo a little bit quickly
here before the full thing reveals.
But Ms..
Marvel is also part of this logo too.
Along with Kang the Conqueror, Nick Fury
and Monica Rambeau travel to Jersey City
to Kamala Khan's house
to talk to her parents
and figure out what's going on with her.
Gina's out on The Avengers again.
Like, Oh my God,
are you here to take me to the Avengers?
This is going to be amazing.
The t shirt she's wearing here actually
has Captain Marvel
comic book covers from real life on it.
You also notice that Monica
Rambeau's uniform looks a lot like her
photon uniform from the comics.
But all the people working for sword
wear uniforms like this,
like they all wear this costume.
I believe she will be going
by the photon name during the movie
when she's explaining her powers.
The whole idea is that in the comics
she can actually manipulate
any type of energy
that she can understand.
She can turn herself
into pure light energy, too.
She can also absorb and redirect
any kind of energy.
She does that with Scarlet Witch's
hex energy, too.
So theoretically, if she could figure out
how to understand how Infinity Stone
Energy works, if someone tried to soak her
with a full blast of all six infinity
stones, the Infinity gantlet,
she could actually redirect
that infinity stone energy at them.
But the way they balance
the power out is by saying that she has
to fully understand how that power works.
And there's just too many questions
about infinity.
So energy,
they don't fully understand it yet.
So it's not like
she can actually do that tomorrow
when they're talking to her
about what's actually going on.
You see her looking at a little dossier
there, the energy,
and you see this wreckage on the floor.
It looks like Carol Danvers
gets into a fight
when she swaps places like Captain
Marvel, winds up fighting a creek
who's tied up.
They're sitting in a chair.
So it looks like when she came downstairs
after swapping places with Ms..
Marvel,
she wound up destroying part of the house.
They had the joke about her,
showing them her power again, causing them
to switch again with Captain Marvel
showing up in the house like, Oh,
Nick Fury, what's going on?
If you didn't watch my Ms..
Marvel episode videos,
Carol Danvers does have a new costume
like this is an upgraded version
of her previous suits.
And they have the joke
about where Ms.. Marvel went.
Like, where did our daughter travel to
if you swapped places with her?
And she jumps to the Kree ship in the
middle of the fight with the Falcon.
That looks like it's
meant to be the same one
from the first movie,
basically using the same joke
that they used during the first Captain
Marvel movie
where all the human characters
were learning about Florence
for the first time, like,
Oh no, no, that's not a cat,
and just opens up with its tentacles
and takes down all the soldiers
freaking Ms..
Marvel out
this foreign planet that they all wind up
traveling to on Captain Marvel ship.
This is meant to be Captain Marvel ship.
She's used for the past many, many years
and she's been in Chris.
School space is meant to be all
Donna is ruled by Prince John.
This character here in his family,
I believe,
is just meant to be part of Chris school
space.
Captain Marvel has visited there before,
so he has like a preexisting history here.
And there's some jokes about her
relationship
with Prince John in the comics.
During the comics,
he accidentally wound up
getting married to him
because of some cultural misunderstanding
that their people had.
Like you see all the dancers here dancing.
That looks kind of
like a traditional Indian dance
like Kamala Khan would have done.
I believe in the comics.
They also communicate on this planet
by singing.
I don't know if they're going to do it
that way.
In the movie, though, the movie itself
isn't meant to be a musical,
but I believe there will be some singing
from the characters during the movie.
You see all three of them on Captain
Marvel ship, getting excited
about going to the planet
like this is after
they come around
on the idea of teaming up.
You see them travel
through one of the jump gates,
just like the Guardians of the Galaxy
do during their movies.
They jump cut a couple of different scenes
of them fighting
and then swapping places with the message,
teaming up changes everything
and everyone like it makes them better
as people learning to be a team together
with Monica Rambeau using her power.
Ms.. Marvel using her power
on one of the cruise ships.
And because Ms..
Marvel and Monica Rambeau
can't naturally fly in the MCU,
they have a joke about them
swapping places
a couple of different times
in falling through the air,
because when they're swapping places,
Captain Marvel had been flying.
We get a much bigger
look at Nick Fury Sword Space Station
when he says Shields up
and you see all the people
wearing the uniforms like Monica Rambeau
in the background, it seems like
this is when Da band, the other Kree
come back to planet Earth to attack.
Like towards the end of the film,
maybe one of the big final fights.
They have a joke about an army of falcon
kittens
like a bunch of kittens running down,
but they're falcons.
They're not actual kittens,
so they're super dangerous.
Like an army of really dangerous
creatures.
This is Zoe Ashton's Dar-Benn character.
She's meant to be ruling the Kree
because the whole idea is that
when this movie picks up, the Kree believe
the Carol Danvers character
actually killed the Supreme Intelligence.
So they view her as a huge villain
to their race.
Like they think of her
as this terrible person
that's going to destroy all of them.
I believe during the movie,
their name for Carol Danvers
is actually the Annihilator.
And that's meant to be a big nihilist
Easter egg for those people
that want to see a nihilist
show up in the MCU as a big villain.
He's actually from the negative zone.
That's the big Fantastic Four place.
Maybe we'll see a nihilist
after they do Fantastic Four.
But you notice that her character
is actually wielding
Ronan, the accuser's hammer,
and you see running the accuser back
behind her walking.
So he's making good on his threat
to Carol Danvers in the first movie.
I will return.
You see all three of them
teaming up in outer space.
And then you see them in a fight
with Darren,
who's wielding the other Bengal,
like Bengal versus Bengal is
they're all swapping places.
Three on one fight year with them,
all using their superpowers
at the same time to, in addition
to the power of the Bengal itself.
And they have another Spider-Man
Iron Man type of Avengers joke where Ms..
Marvel is nerding out about them
being a team together in the older members
like Monica Rambeau, Captain Marvel
don't to have anything to do with that.
Like Iron Man was really tired
with all of Spider-Man's
pop culture references,
like Take it easy, kid, just calm down,
until eventually he came around.
It came to be very close to Spider-Man.
The whole idea in this movie is
they're meant to go
through the same type of arc
where initially only Ms..
Marvel is excited
about having to team up together,
and eventually they all come around
and they start to feel kind of like
sisters by the end of the film.
But if it wasn't clear the ship that
they're on here is Captain Marvel ship.
It's the same ship like she's been on it
this whole time, which is why
there are all these knickknacks
in the background.
You see some eighties artifacts
in the background, too.
And you notice in the Marvel's
logo for the movie, the S is represented
by Kamala Khan's s, but the logo itself
is meant to represent all three characters
like the star in the middle of the
A represents Monica Rambeau.
The rest of it represents Carol Danvers,
Captain Marvel character.
Like I said, though, holding out hope
for another marvel to show up in the movie
are some Easter eggs for that
with a Blue Marvel character.
But I'm not going to hold my breath on it.
And I believe the movie's
supposed to go out on an actual incursion
in the whole time.
Runs out.
Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty,
the lead up to Secret Wars.
They keep referencing the incursions
during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
during the other films recently.
So I think the idea is that now
we're finally going to see what happened,
where two universes
start to collide with each other
because of what's happening
with the Bangles.
If you spotted any of their Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them, blow in the comments.
I'm sure there's going to be a ton
of questions about everybody's character,
how their powers work, and the other stuff
that they're going to be setting up during
the film.
We're actually getting pretty close
to Avengers five.
There were a whole bunch of Star Wars
trailers.
The drop that Star Wars celebration
I'm still working on videos for,
so make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss those.
My next big video will be for The
Mandalorian Season three Episode seven.
Everyone click here for that
brand new Ahsoka trailer and click here
for that brand new Star Wars
acolyte trailer and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.